rejoignez-moi sur patréon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas très on
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Marx et de
la lutte des classes
l'expression de lutte déclass n'a pas
été inventé par Marx elle a été inventée
par François Guizot un historien
français du XIXe siècle historien
libéral soit dit en passant
mais c'est Marx qui va populariser cette
expression et qui va même en faire l'une
des idées maîtresses de sa philosophie
alors avant d'expliquer ce qu'est la
lutte des classes on rappellera que Marx
est un philosophe et économiste allemand
il a d'abord fait des études de droit
avant de s'orienter vers la philosophie
puis vers l'économie c'est quelqu'un qui
a littéralement sacrifié sa vie pour son
oeuvre et pour ses idées il a subi la
censure les expulsions il allait de
payer en pays pour fuir les persécutions
et bien qu'il fut d'ascendance
bourgeoise il a vécu une grande partie
de sa vie dans la misère la plus totale
Marx croyait dans ses idées il croyait
dans son combat son combat pour
l'avènement du communisme et aujourd'hui
on va se pencher sur ce qu'il appelait
la lutte des classes pour tenter de
comprendre quelle vision avec Marx des
rapports économiques et des rapports
sociaux
alors avant toute chose il faut préciser
que sur le plan philosophique Marx c'est
ce qu'on appelle un matérialiste
matérialiste ça veut dire qu'il
considère que la matière est première
par rapport aux idées
que le monde est fait de matière et que
les idées ne sont que des émanations de
la matière
d'ailleurs Marx a été très influencé par
les penseurs matérialistes de
l'Antiquité il a fait sa thèse de
doctorat sur Démocrite et Épicure et
même si on réduit souvent Marx à sa
pensée économique on peut pas comprendre
sa pensée économique si on comprend pas
la philosophie qui est en arrière-plan
donc le matérialisme de Marx c'est de
dire que le monde est constitué de
rapports matériels que la pensée que la
conscience sont le reflet de ces
rapports matériels autrement dit que
nous avons les idées de notre situation
sociale
il y a deux citations de Marx qui
illustrent bien ça première citation ce
n'est pas la conscience des hommes qui
détermine leur être c'est au contraire
leur être social qui détermine leur
conscience
deuxième citation le mouvement de la
pensée n'est que la réflexion du
mouvement réel transportée et transposée
dans le cerveau de l'homme
donc on Mars ce ne sont pas les idées
qui guident le monde et qui font
survenir les actions et les événements
ce sont les actions et les événements
qui guident le monde et qui font naître
les idées
et si je prends le temps de vous
expliquer ça c'est pour vous faire
comprendre que pour Marx c'est
l'économie qui façonne le monde parce
que l'économie c'est ce qui structure
l'intégralité des rapports matériels
et donc l'intégralité des rapports
sociaux c'est-à-dire des rapports
humains
c'est l'économie qui façonne votre vie
professionnelle
votre rapport à vos collègues à votre
patron ou à vos employés
le salaire que vous touchez
les tâches que vous effectuez
et par ricochet la maison vous habitez
votre quartier votre environnement
social donc vos fréquentations vos
habitudes
l'économie c'est ce qui façonne votre
rapport à la consommation
à la technologie
et on peut même aller encore plus loin
l'économie façonne votre éducation
le type d'école où vous irez école
privée ou école publique
les études que vous allez suivre grande
école ou faculté
donc l'économie détermine tout le reste
et c'est d'ailleurs le grand pouvoir de
l'économie d'agir sur nous sans même que
l'on s'en rende compte
de nous faire considérer notre condition
économique au social comme une sorte de
fait naturel
comme une sorte d'évidence ou de non
événements
ce qui fait qu'on ne s'interroge même
pas sur notre condition sociale et
encore moins sur les causes de notre
condition sociale
au quotidien on ne se dit pas que notre
situation sociale c'est le résultat d'un
rapport de force historique entre des
exploitants et des exploités
on ne se dit pas que notre existence
individuelle et collective et structuré
par des rapports de production qui sont
définis par notre position dans
l'appareil de production
on n'a pas conscience de tout ça
et pourtant on le vit
ce que nous dit Marx c'est que nous
devons prendre conscience que la société
est organisée en classe sociale dont les
deux principales sont la classe
capitaliste la bourgeoisie et la classe
des travailleurs le prolétariat
la classe capitaliste c'est celle qui
possède les moyens de production et qui
fait travailler les prolétaires pour
s'enrichir
et le prolétariat c'est la classe qui
possède rien rien si ce n'est sa force
de travail
sa force de travail qu'elle vend aux
propriétaires capitalistes en échange
d'un salaire
la bourgeoisie c'est la classe qui
s'enrichit
le prolétariat c'est la classe qui
survit
pour Marx l'histoire de l'humanité c'est
l'histoire de la lutte larvée ou déclaré
entre ces deux classes sociales
antagonistes que sont les propriétaires
et les prolétaires
je disais à l'instant que le propre de
l'économie c'était d'agir sur nous sans
que l'on s'en rende compte
autrement dit nous sommes pour la
plupart dans une inconscience de classe
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que dans notre vie
quotidienne nous interagissons
majoritairement avec des individus
faisant partie de notre classe sociale
nos collègues de travail nos amis notre
famille
alors bien sûr il y a des exceptions
un salarié peut avoir comme ami des
grands patrons
et inversement un grand patron peut
avoir comme ami les salariés
mais globalement ça reste une minorité
globalement les salariés ont des amis
salariés et les grands patrons ont des
amis grand patron
on parle pas de branches de métier on
parle de position dans l'appareil de
production
on parle d'un groupe qui vit en faisant
travailler les autres et d'un groupe qui
vit en vendant sa force de travail
étant entendu que ceux qui vendent leurs
forces de travail sont de loin les plus
nombreux
donc tout ça pour dire quoi tout ça pour
dire que quand on évolue dans un univers
social composé de gens qui partagent
notre condition sociale
on ne se le dit pas
on ne se fait pas la remarque
notre univers social c'est notre univers
tout court
donc on ne le voit même pas comme un
univers
et on ne pense pas à l'univers qui est
au-dessus d'une autre et qui détermine
nos conditions d'existence
on sait qu'on travaille pour un patron
on sait qu'au dessus de nous dans la
hiérarchie il y a des gens qui possèdent
l'entreprise où on travaille
mais on ne les croise jamais
on ne les pratiques jamais
c'est la scène de Germinal ou l'entier
demanda à bonne mort à qui appartient la
mine de charbon
et bonne mort lui répond on n'en sait
rien à des gens
à des gens
il n'y a pas nous et vous
il y a nous et il
voyez pourquoi j'ai insisté sur le
matérialisme de Marx
parce que c'est aussi ça avoir une
approche matérialiste des choses
c'est s'arrêter sur les interactions
concrètes
sur les rapports concrets
les rapports concrets dont on ne
s'étonne plus parce qu'ils sont
normalisés
dans la mine on croise le rouleur on
croise le mouliner le lampiste
on croise pas le propriétaire
et encore aujourd'hui les classes
sociales vivent séparées
les riches ont leur quartier les pauvres
ont les leurs
lieux de sortie leur lieu de loisirs et
les pauvres ont les leurs
chacun chez soi et les bénéfices seront
bien gardés
on voit très bien ce phénomène chez les
célébrités les stars
qui se rencontrent dans des soirées de
stars qui ont des conversations de star
qui se marient dans des mariages de
stars et qui font des enfants de star
pas besoin de recourir au concept de
ghettoïsation
les structures économiques de la société
sont organisés de telle sorte que les
classes sociales ne se mélangent pas
donc au quotidien on fréquente d'abord
des membres de notre classe
et c'est ce qui fait qu'une classe
sociale ne développe pas forcément ce
que Marx appelle une conscience de
classe
on peut être ouvrir sans se définir et
même sans se représenter comme un membre
de la classe ouvrière
et d'ailleurs c'est même un des leviers
de la domination capitaliste
d'empêcher les prolétaires de développer
une conscience de classe
autrement dit de les empêcher de se voir
et de se penser comme une classe
opprimée
dans le cahier des charges de la
bourgeoisie il n'y a pas seulement
l'exploitation économique
il y a aussi l'Allier nation idéologique
c'est-à-dire le processus par lequel les
prolétaires sont dépossédés de leur
conscience
ça aussi ça prend des formes très
concrètes
de nos jours la télévision le cinéma et
même une certaine littérature ont pour
fonction de nous faire oublier notre
appartenance de classe
on va regarder une série mettant en
scène des bourgeois
et on va s'identifier
on va même pas remarquer que ce sont des
bourgeois
on va voir des personnages qui vivent
tout un tas d'aventures sans se rendre
compte qu'à aucun moment ces personnages
ne sont confrontés à la réalité qui est
la nôtre
la réalité sociale qui est la nôtre
les factures et crédits les privations
on s'identifie à des personnages qui
sont des personnages affranchis de
l'impératif de production
et ce faisant on se pense soi-même comme
affranchi de sa classe sociale
notre conscience de classe est aliénée
marxet les idées dominantes sont les
idées de la classe dominante
il voulait dire par là que l'idéologie
dominante dans une société capitaliste
c'est l'idéologie qui profite au
capitalisme
c'est l'idéologie qui empêche le
prolétariat d'accéder à la conscience de
soi
et c'est là qu'on en arrive à la
distinction établie Marx entre ce qu'il
appelle une classe en soi et une classe
pour soi
une classe en soi c'est une classe comme
réalité objective c'est une classe qui
existe dans la société mais sans avoir
nécessairement conscience d'être une
classe
une classe pour soi c'est une classe qui
a accédé à la conscience de soi
autrement dit c'est une classe qui a
conscience de ses intérêts en tant que
classe sociale
et qui peut donc s'organiser pour
défendre ses intérêts de classe
et donc quand je disais qu'on n'avait
pas forcément conscience de son
appartement de classe en réalité les
bourgeois ont une conscience de classe
en tout cas ils l'ont tendancièrement
beaucoup plus que les prolétaires
pourquoi parce que les bourgeois ont des
intérêts
ils ont des intérêts que les prolétaires
n'ont pas
et donc devant protéger leurs intérêts
ils développent nécessairement la
conscience de ses intérêts
donc la conscience de classe
pour Marx la bourgeoisie a une
conscience de classe naturellement plus
développée puisqu'en tant que classe
dominante c'est elle qui détient les
moyens de production
elle a quelque chose à surveiller
c'est ça qui la rend consciente
et quand la bourgeoisie est menacée dans
ses intérêts elle se mobilise
elle ne se mobilise pas de façon
directement visible
elle ne descend pas dans la rue
la rue c'est pour les pauvres
la rue c'est pour ceux qui n'ont pas
d'autres moyens de défendre leurs
intérêts que de descendre dans la rue
ou de faire grève on va y revenir
la bourgeoisie elle ne descend pas dans
la rue elle utilise des leviers d'action
structurel
et licenciement les délocalisations
les restructurations
et les lois
n'oublions pas que pour Marx la
politique et le bras armé de l'économie
et la police le bras armé de la
politique
les forces de l'ordre capitaliste
et donc quand je disais que la
conscience de classe de la bourgeoisie
venait du fait qu'elle avait des
intérêts à défendre ça ne veut pas dire
que le prolétariat n'a pas d'intérêt
ça veut dire que les intérêts du
prolétariat ne sont pas compatibles avec
les intérêts de la bourgeoisie
ça veut dire que quand on est dominé on
ne peut pas faire valoir ses intérêts
aussi efficacement que les dominants
précisément parce que ces intérêts sont
contradictoires avec les intérêts des
dominants
bien sûr que les dominés ont des
intérêts
l'intérêt des dominés c'est
l'émancipation
l'intérêt des dominés c'est l'égalité
précisément ce dont les dominants ne
veulent pas
parce que du point de vue des
capitalistes l'émancipation des
prolétaires ça veut dire la fin de
l'exploitation
l'égalité sociale ça veut dire la mort
des privilèges
les capitalistes tiennent à leur
privilège
ils ne veulent pas rogner sur leur
et c'est ce qui fait qu'à certaines
occasions dans l'histoire les
prolétaires ont dû recourir à la
violence pour récupérer des intérêts qui
leur avait été confisqué
par exemple lors de la Révolution de
pas celle de 1789 pour Marx 1789 ça
d'abord été une révolution bourgeoise
ça a été le remplacement d'un régime de
domination qui était la féodalité par un
nouveau régime de domination qui était
le capitalisme
les prolétaires en l'occurrence la
paysannerie non pas vu leurs conditions
améliorées
donc il faut bien s'entendre sur le fait
que la Révolution française de 1789 ce
n'est pas une révolution prolétaire
c'est au contraire la mise en place du
capitalisme
et les droits de l'homme
issus de la Révolution française ce sont
les droits de l'homme bourgeois
pas les droits du prolétaire
mais Marx dira quand même que cette
révolution a eu un intérêt à l'intérêt
majeur même parce qu'elle a constitué
une étape et un progrès dans la lutte
des classes
Marx a une vision dialectique de
l'histoire
ça veut dire que pour lui même si un
événement apparaît comme opposé à son
idéal il est une étape dans la
réalisation de cet idéal
autrement dit un événement apparemment
négatif constitue toujours un pas
supplémentaire vers un résultat qui lui
est positif
c'est ça une vision dialectique
c'est considérer que le négatif est un
moment du positif
que le négatif est un moteur et un
promoteur du positif
donc si il est clair que la Révolution
française a entraîné l'avènement du
capitalisme il fallait l'avènement du
capitalisme pour que s'organise les
forces anticapitalistes
il fallait l'avènement du capitalisme
pour accélérer le processus de
conscientisation de l'exploitation
capitaliste
toujours selon l'idée que ce sont les
événements qui déterminent la conscience
pour Marx la lutte des classes la lutte
entre les propriétaires capitalistes et
les prolétaires ce n'est pas une lutte
morale
c'est une lutte historique
marxe pas la lutte des classes en termes
de bien ou de mal
il analyse en termes de rapport de force
en termes de processus marqués par tel
et telle étape conduisant à tel ou tel
résultat
c'est d'ailleurs ça l'origine de
l'expression socialisme scientifique qui
désigne une approche purement technique
des rapports de force économique
la question n'est pas de savoir si les
justes ou injuste que les prolétaires
soient exploités par les capitalistes
la question est de savoir comment ça se
fait
comment ça marche la domination
par où ça passe et à quoi ça mène
c'est ça le socialisme scientifique
on prend les mécanismes de la domination
capitaliste et comprendre pourquoi
chaque pas en avant du capitalisme est
en réalité un pas en avant vers son
abolition
parce qu'il faut que le capitalisme se
développe pour que ces contradictions
apparaissent
il faut qu'il aille au bout de sa
logique pour qu'il s'autodétruisent
le marxisme est une dialectique du
rapport de force
et c'est là qu'on va pouvoir joindre les
deux bouts de la ficelle parce que
rappelez-vous ce qu'on a dit on a dit
premièrement que l'histoire de
l'humanité était l'histoire de la lutte
des classes et que deuxièmement le
prolétariat était empêché par la
bourgeoisie d'accéder à la conscience de
classe
donc on pourrait se dire en première
analyse que le prolétariat est battu
d'avance
il y a justement vous allez voir que non
parce que si l'histoire du monde et
l'histoire de la lutte des classes la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est
qu'est-ce qu'une lutte sinon une
occasion
d'accéder à la conscience de soi
suivez le raisonnement
dans une lutte on a un adversaire
un adversaire par rapport auquel on se
positionne
et donc par rapport auquel on se définit
quand un groupe d'ouvriers fait grève et
que le patron daigne enfin s'adresser à
eux généralement on leur demandait de
reprendre le travail les ouvriers savent
qu'ils sont
ils sont les ouvriers
ils sont ceux qui réclament de
meilleures conditions de travail
ou un meilleur salaire
ou de ne pas être licencié parce que le
patron a décidé de délocaliser
l'entreprise
c'est ça le terreau matériel de la
Solidarité sociale
la lutte
la lutte face à un adversaire qui a le
contrôle sur nos intérêts
sur nos intérêts communs
donc que font les ouvriers quand ils
font grève
ils prennent conscience de leur
appartenance de classe
en faisant cause commune ils font corps
comme un
ils deviennent une entité collective
la lutte est un vecteur de la conscience
de soi
et dans le cas du prolétariat c'est
encore plus puissant
parce que quand il lutte ont-ils fait
grève ou quand il refuse d'obéir le
prolétariat se rend bien compte que les
capitalistes ne sont pas contents
que ça les dérange quand ils font grève
que ça casse la productivité donc la
rentabilité
quand ils font grève les ouvriers
peuvent se rendre compte ils le savent
déjà mais là il observe qu'il possède un
moyen de pression redoutable sur les
capitalistes
leur travail
leur force de travail
et cette force de travail les
capitalistes ne peuvent pas s'en passer
ce que font les prolétaires les
capitalistes ne pourraient pas le faire
les capitalistes ont besoin des
prolétaires
sans les prolétaires les capitalistes ne
peuvent plus faire de profit
ils ne peuvent plus toucher leur rente
ou leur dividendes
sans les prolétaires les capitalistes
n'existent plus
la supériorité du prolétaire sur le
capitalisme c'est la relation de
dépendance non pas qui le lit au
capitalisme mais par laquelle le
capitaliste est lié à lui
que va faire un patron dans une usine en
grève
il va remplacer l'ouvrier
il ne sait même pas comment on allume la
machine
sans le prolétaire le propriétaire est
démuni
cette relation de dépendance entre le
prolétaire et le propriétaire
c'est une relation qui a été
philosophiquement décrite par Eagle à
travers ce qu'il appelle la dialectique
du maître et de l'esclave
parfois traduit en dialectique du maître
et du serviteur
c'est une image pour traduire le
renversement de situation qui s'opère
entre le travailleur et l'exploitant
lorsque le travailleur se rend compte
que l'exploitant a besoin de lui
il a besoin de lui pour pouvoir
continuer à jouir de son travail
donc c'est un texte qui se trouve dans
la Phénoménologie de l'Esprit publiée en
1807 et qu'on peut résumer de la façon
suivante
le maître fait travailler l'esclave
l'esclave produit le maître consomme
l'esclave est actif le maître est passif
au bout d'un moment
l'esclave se rend compte qu'il y a
quelque chose qui cloche
ce qui cloche c'est qu'il obéit à
quelqu'un qui a besoin de lui
l'esclave lui n'a besoin de personne
il sait travailler il s'est produit il
est autonome
le maître lui était terronome
il est en situation de dépendance
le maître devient donc
l'esclave de l'esclave
et bien pour Marx cette image illustre
parfaitement ce qui s'opère dans la
conscience du travailleur lorsqu'il est
en lutte
la prise de conscience que c'est lui qui
a le pouvoir
la prise de conscience que c'est lui
l'élément indispensable
parce qu'il voit bien que lorsqu'il est
désobéit le propriétaire a les mains
liée
que son pouvoir s'évanouit dès lors que
le prolétaire lui retire ce pouvoir
n'oublions pas que l'autorité
c'est le fait d'être autorisé
si le prolétaire n'autorise plus le
propriétaire à exercer son pouvoir sur
lui ce pouvoir n'existe plus
donc la conscience de classe c'est ce
qui émerge de la lutte des classes
et quand les prolétaires prendront
conscience que les capitalistes ne sont
rien sans eux quand ils prendront
conscience contre les capitalistes et le
prolétariat c'est le prolétariat qui a
le pouvoir pas le pouvoir juridique pas
le pouvoir institutionnel mais le
pouvoir réel et que le pouvoir
institutionnel s'effondre sous le
pouvoir réel lorsque le prolétariat
prendra conscience de ça nous dit Marx
ce sera la révolution
au sens littéral
l'exploitation capitaliste sera révolue
ce sera l'avènement d'une société sans
classe
j'aimerais m'arrêter un instant sur ce
projet qui avait Marx d'une société sans
classe pour montrer qu'il ne s'agissait
pas seulement d'un projet mais de ce
qu'il appelait une nécessité
nécessité en philosophie ça ne veut pas
dire besoin
ça veut dire inévitable
la révolution prolétarienne selon Marx
était inévitable
elle était inévitable parce qu'en se
développant le capitalisme crée
mécaniquement des contradictions
internes
des contradictions internes qui le
mèneront à l'effondrement
autrement dit en se développant le
capitalisme crée les conditions de son
auto abolition
Marx croit au sens de l'histoire
il croit à un terme ultime de l'histoire
qui au bout de millénaire de lutte entre
dominants et dominés
débouchera sur la fin de l'histoire
la fin de l'histoire ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il ne se passera plus rien
mais ça veut dire qu'il ne se passera
plus rien d'historiquement déterminant
ça veut dire que le moteur de l'histoire
qu'est la lutte des classes n'existera
plus
et que donc les événements qui
surviendront n'auront pas une portée
signifiante sur le devenir de l'humanité
cette vision d'un sens de l'histoire
Marx l'emprunte à eagle
Hegel qui comme on l'a vu fut l'une des
grandes influences de Marx mais dont il
a totalement modifié le principe
originel
que disait Hegel
Hegel disait que l'histoire était guidée
par la raison
que l'histoire était guidée par l'idée
avec un I majuscule
idée qui s'incarnait dans la matière et
qui se déployait à travers l'histoire
autrement dit Eagle était un idéaliste
idéaliste au sens philosophique au sens
où pour lui c'est l'idée qui prime sur
la matière et non pas l'inverse
tandis que Marx pensait au contraire que
c'était la matière qui au travers du
mouvement de l'histoire faisait émerger
l'esprit
et donc que le développement matériel du
capitalisme finirait par engendrer la
conscience de ce qu'est le capitalisme
Marx a opéré ce qu'on appelle le
renversement matérialiste de la
philosophie égale
il a remis la philosophie de Hegel sur
ses pieds
les pieds dans la matière
et donc c'est ce qui fait que pour Marx
les idées n'ont finalement qu'un rôle
auxiliaire dans la révolution
prolétarienne
roloxiliaire ça veut dire que les idées
ne font qu'accompagner l'action
elle surgissent de l'action
comme dans l'exemple de la dialectique
du maître et de l'esclave dans laquelle
la prise de conscience de l'esclave est
une émanation de son rapport de force
avec le maître
les prolétaires ne théorisent pas la
Révolution il LA FONT
et c'est parce qu'il la font que les
intellectuels peuvent passer derrière
pour la théoriser
sauf que Marx c'est celui qui a théorisé
la révolution prolétarienne non pas
après quel ait eu lieu mais avant
qu'elle ait eu lieu
parce que pour lui
l'effondrement du capitalisme et
prévisible
il a anticipé
et en anticipant l'effondrement du
capitalisme il a en même temps anticipé
l'inéluctabilité d'une révolution
prolétarienne
la théorisation du capitalisme par Marx
c'est l'anticipation par le concept des
conséquences inévitables du capitalisme
et la conséquence inévitable du
capitalisme c'est la révolution
si Marc s'était convaincu que la
révolution prolétarienne allait arriver
ce n'est pas parce qu'il lisait dans le
marc de café
ou parce qu'il avait un penchant au
mysticisme
ce que certains ont d'ailleurs
reprochait à Eagle une sorte de vision
messianique de l'esprit qui un jour
viendrait consacrer l'union du divin et
de l'humain
Marx n'est pas du tout là-dedans
pour lui ce qui rend la révolution
prolétérienne inéluctable ce sont les
contradictions internes du capitalisme
prenons l'une des contradictions du
capitalisme
la logique du capitalisme c'est
l'accumulation
l'accumulation indéfinie
la devise du capitalisme c'est toujours
plus
d'ailleurs on trouve des textes de Marx
dans lesquels il parle explicitement de
la nature vorace du capitalisme
le capitalisme c'est un monstre
insatiable
la forme économique de lubris
donc si la nature du capitalisme c'est
la croissance indéfinie ça veut dire que
le capitalisme a besoin de toujours
faire baisser les coûts de production
ça peut être par l'utilisation de
technologie plus avancées
ça peut être en augmentant la
productivité
ça peut aussi être en baissant les
salaires des ouvriers
dans tous les cas les possibilités sont
limitées
donc si un patron cherche à faire
toujours plus de profit il va fatalement
atteindre un point limite
ce qui va leur arriver c'est une
diminution des bénéfices
ce que Marx appelle la baisse
tendancielle du taux de profit
les entreprises les moins compétitives
vont alors se faire absorber par les
plus compétitives ce qui va entraîner
fatalement une concentration du capital
et donc on va se retrouver avec de très
grandes entreprises qui accaparent toute
la richesse et qui pour maximiser leur
profit vont faire encore plus pression
sur les salaires
ou vont augmenter leur prix
autrement dit on va se retrouver avec
des travailleurs de plus en plus pauvres
qui vont payer des marchandises de plus
en plus cher
jusqu'au moment où ce système va
atteindre sa limite ou le capital ne
pourra plus accroître et où la
population ne pourra plus vivre
c'est alors que le capitalisme va
connaître la crise
pour Marx la crise du capitalisme est
inéluctable
et si les prolétaires ayant accédé à la
conscience de classe
s'organise et s'unissent
leur conscience de classe deviendra en
science révolutionnaire
une fois émancipée des faux conflits des
conflits horizontaux entretenus par la
classe capitaliste pour empêcher l'Union
des travailleurs le prolétariat sera
alors en situation d'agir
en situation de renverser la classe
capitaliste de mettre un terme à
l'exploitation et de faire advenir une
société sans classe
une société où les moyens de production
sont mis en commun
une société où il n'y a plus ni maître
ni serviteur
mais où la fraternité est garante de
l'égalité
je cite
l'histoire de toute société jusqu'à nos
jours n'a été que l'histoire de lutte de
classe homme libre et esclave patricien
et plébéien Baron et serre maître de
Gironde et compagnon en un mot
oppresseur et au primé en opposition
constante ont mené une guerre
ininterrompue tantôt dissimuler tantôt
ouvertes une guerre qui finissait
toujours soit par une transformation
révolutionnaire de la société tout
entière soit par la destruction des deux
classes en lutte la société bourgeoise
moderne élevée sur les ruines de la
société féodale n'a pas aboli les
antagonistes de classe elle n'a fait que
substituer de nouvelles classes de
nouvelles conditions d'oppression de
nouvelles formes de lutte à celle
d'autrefois cependant le caractère
distinctif de notre époque de l'époque
de la bourgeoisie et d'avoir simplifié
les antagonistes de classe la société se
divise de plus en plus en deux vastes
camps opposés en deux grandes classes
directement ennemies la bourgeoisie et
le prolétariat la bourgeoisie a joué
dans l'histoire un rôle essentiellement
révolutionnaire partout où elle a
conquis le pouvoir elle a foulé au pied
les relations féodales patriarcales et
idyllique tous les liens bariolés qui
unissaient l'homme féodal à ses
supérieurs naturels elle les a brisés
sans pitié pour ne laisser subsister
d'autres liens entre l'homme et l'homme
que le froid intérêt le dur paiement
comptant elle a noyé l'extase religieuse
l'enthousiasme chevaleresque la
sentimentalité petite bourgeoise dans
les eaux glacées du calcul égoïstes elle
a fait de la dignité personnelle une
simple valeur d'échanges elle a
substitué aux nombreuses libertés si
cherment conquise l'unique et
impitoyable liberté du commerce en un
mot à la place de l'exploitation voilée
par des illusions religieuses et
politiques elle a mis une exploitation
ouverte et hontée direct brutale la
bourgeoisie a dépouillé de leur auréole
toutes les professions qui passaient
jusque là pour vénéra et qu'on
considérait avec un saint respect le
médecin le juriste le prêtre le poète le
savant elle les a enrôlés parmi les
travailleurs salariés la bourgeoisie
n'existe qu'à condition de révolutionner
sans cesse les instruments de travail ce
qui veut dire le mode de production ce
qui veut dire tous les rapports sociaux
le maintien de l'ancien mode de
production était au contraire pour
toutes les classes industrielles
antérieures la condition première de
leur existence ce bouleversement
continuel de mode de production se
constant ébranlement de tout le système
social cette agitation et cette
insécurité perpétuelle distingue
l’époque bourgeoise de toutes les
précédentes tous les rapports sociaux
traditionnels et figés avec leur cortège
de croyance et d'idées anciennement
vénérés se dissolvent ceux qui les
remplacent vieillissent avant d'avoir pu
Saucier tout ce qui avait sollicité et
permanence s'envole comme fumée tout ce
qui était sacré et profané et les hommes
sont forcés enfin d'envis leurs
conditions d'existence et leur relation
réciproque avec des yeux désabusés
poussés par le besoin de déboucher
toujours nouveau la bourgeoisie envahit
le globe entier il lui faut pénétrer
partout s'établir partout créé partout
des moyens de communication par
l'exploitation du marché mondial la
bourgeoisie donne un caractère
cosmopolite à la production et à la
consommation de tous les pays au
désespoir des réactionnaires elle a
enlevé à l'industrie sa base nationale
les vieilles industries nationales sont
détruites ou sur le point de l'être les
armes dont la bourgeoisie s'est servi
pour rabattre la féodalité se retourne
aujourd'hui contre la bourgeoisie
elle-même mais la bourgeoisie n'a pas
seulement forgé les armes qui la
mettront à mort elle a produit aussi les
hommes qui maniront ses armes les
ouvriers modernes les prolétaires avec
le développement de la bourgeoisie
c'est-à-dire du capital se développe le
prolétariat la classe des ouvriers
modernes qui ne vivent qu'à la condition
de trouver du travail et qu'il en trouve
aussi leur travail accroît le capital
ces ouvriers contraint de se vendre au
jour le jour sont une marchandise un
article de commerce comme un autre il
subisse par conséquent toutes les
vicissitudes de la concurrence toutes
les fluctuations du marché
l'introduction des machines et la
division du travail en dépouillant la
fonction de l'ouvrier de toute
personnalité lui ont fait perdre tout un
trait le producteur devient un simple
appendice de la machine on exige de lui
que l'opération la plus simple la plus
monotone la plus vite à prise par
conséquent ce que coûte aujourd'hui
l'ouvrier se réduit à peu de choses près
au coût de ce qui lui faut pour
s'entretenir et perpétuer sa race or le
prix du travail comme celui de toute
marchandise est égal à son coût de
production donc que le travail devient
répugnant plus les salaires baissent
bien plus la somme de labeur s'accroît
avec le développement du machinisme et
de la division du travail soit par
l'augmentation des heures ouvrables soit
par l'accélération du mouvement des
machines et donc du labeur exigé pour un
temps donné de toutes les classes qui à
leur présentent se trouvent face à face
avec la bourgeoisie le prolétariat seul
est une masse vraiment révolutionnaire
les autres classes périclite et
périssent avec la grande industrie le
prolétariat au contraire en est le
produit le plus spécial toutes les
classes qui dans le passé s'emparer du
pouvoir essayez de consolider leur
situation acquise en soumettant la
société à leur propre mode
d'appropriation les prolétaires ne
peuvent s'emparer des forces productives
sociales quand abolissant le mode
d'appropriation qui était particulier à
celle-ci et par suite tout mode
d'appropriation en vigueur jusqu'à nos
jours les prolétaires n'ont rien à
sauvegarder qui leur appartiennent ils
ont à détruire toute garantie privée
toute sécurité privée existante en
esquissant à grand trait les phases du
développement prolétariat nous avons
retracé l'histoire de la guerre civile
plus ou moins latente
qui travaille la société jusqu'à l'heure
où cette guerre éclate en révolution
ouverte et où le prolétariat fondra sa
domination par le renversement violent
de la bourgeoisie
les tentatives de mise en application du
marxisme qui ont eu lieu dans différents
pays du monde au 20e siècle le RSS la
Chine Cuba
ce sont soldés par des échecs
au lieu d’état communiste
au lieu de société ou l'homme et l'allié
de l'homme
on s'est retrouvé avec des régimes
bureaucratiques
exploitant les travailleurs
au nom de l'idéal égalitaire
preuve s'il en est que derrière de
grands idéaux peuvent se dissimuler des
motivations beaucoup plus villes
à la fin de sa vie Marx a écrit tout ce
que je sais c'est que je ne suis pas
marxiste
c'était une manière pour lui de prendre
ses distances avec les interprétations
qu'on avait faites de son œuvre
et si Marx revenait parmi nous il serait
intéressant de savoir ce qu'il pense de
ceux qui se réclament de lui
de ceux pour qui la lutte n'est pas une
nécessité
mais un moyen d'exister
et de se présenter au monde et à
eux-mêmes
comme attaché à la cause des dominés
être marxiste est-ce seulement si tes
Marx
ou s
agir dans le sens de l'émancipation
de l'émancipation réelle
[Musique]
la religion et l'opium du peuple a
également écrit Marx
une phrase que les marxistes ne
considèrent jamais comme pouvant
s'adresser à eux
et qui pourtant s'adresse à eux comme
elle s'adresse à tous ceux qui ont
besoin de sacraliser un texte
pour se sentir du côté du bien
je vous remercie
[Musique]